good to see you honey I feel like I like
robust ease now I hope that's what
everyone saying back at et to you Andrea
like girls Nasim Joe don't be hatin okay
not at all I feel like you've had so
much though to celebrate going on in
your life right now from the foundation
to Fenty now this the book in a visual
autobiography one thousand photographs
15 pounds of reread that book is heavy
yeah oh you remembered all that
animation huh I was finger through the
book over there oh but yeah it is a
piece of art that I am really proud of
because I've been working on it for over
five years it's something that I feel
like my fans really really want they
want a piece of art they want a piece of
a collection of memories that I can
share with them some of which they've
shared with me some of which that they
have no clue of and it's a little bit of
insight a little bit of um if you if you
were never a fan of leave you kind of
get a bit of insight into who I am
surprised the most about this book
oh I mean there are a lot of personal
images and a lot of images that my fans
have never seen before and I think
that's what they're gravitating towards
you know not just my Instagram printed
in the book right they want to know what
else is there what else are we missing
what do you do when we don't see you and
this is a lot of insight to that and I
think that's the the special gem about
this book this project any photos you
don't remember taking oh every photo
it's like a memory and so when you see
it you're like you go right back to the
days the place yeah how you felt
who was there so it's just it's
enjoyable for me and finally another
piece of art that your fans are really
looking forward to you've given them a
glimpse into your upcoming album so can
we get a clue as to maybe what the title
might be I hear you've registered
private loving that's no that's not
that's not true okay it's not going to
be the title
give me something about the album read
um pending I could get a dot a dot and a
dot reggae thank you yes you already
knew that though we besties you should
know I'm trying to get you to expand
mama you know why it's it's Navy a
little but the thing is when I have more
information you will be the first to
know and I will gladly vomit that out
here on a red carpet
how's that for you Kevin Frazier
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]